madame mademoiselle monsieur bonsoir la
démocratie chrétienne sept minutes le
rpr ce soir monsieur jacques chirac cinq
minutes
l'union pour la démocratie française
représentée par monsieur jean pierre
soisson quatre minutes enfin monsieur
françois mitterrand durant neuf minutes
au nom du parti socialiste
voilà quel est le programme que nous
vous offrons ce soir sur antenne 2 de
20h35 à 21h05
nous ne sommes d'ailleurs pas les seuls
à vous le proposez tf1 fr 3 ou si vous
préférez la radio france inter ont eux
aussi ce soir les mêmes têtes d'affichés
politiques à vous proposer
la campagne officielle à la radio et à
la télé pour les élections législatives
du mois de mars prochain commence
aujourd'hui c'est à dire que tous les
jours pendant deux semaines sauf le
samedi le dimanche
vous aurez ainsi rendez-vous chaque soir
durant une demi heure avec les partis
candidats à ces élections
certains sont très connus le pc le ps le
rpr l'udf le émerger j'espère que je
n'en n'oublie pas d'autres le sont moins
vous pourrez ainsi faire leur
connaissance est partie peu connue ce
fonds le front autogestionnaire vous le
retrouverez demain l'union ouvrières et
paysannes pour la démocratie
prolétarienne qui aura sept minutes père
crédit et puis aussi le rassemblement
des usagers des services publics des
contribuables et des mouvements de
défense qui aura sept minutes lundi
prochain pour s'exprimer
le mécanisme de cette campagne
officielle sur les ondes est un peu
compliqué alors en gros sachez que la
majorité et l'opposition
on a même temps de parole etc en outre
toutes les formations présentant au
moins 75 candidats bénéficient d'ici au
1er tour de sept minutes pour s'exprimer
à la radio et à la télévision
la majorité comme l'opposition en une
heure et demie pour vous convaincre
au sein de cette majorité comme os à
l'opposition le temps d'antenne est
fonction de la représentation de chaque
partie au sein de l'actuelle assemblée
l'ordre de passage de son côté est tiré
au sort à la alors cela veut-il dire que
dans le temps qui leur est attribuée les
parties ont la possibilité de faire tout
ce qu'ils veulent
et bien ne le croyez pas les règles sont
très strictes et chacun sait aujourd'hui
ce qu'ils peuvent faire ou bien ne pas
faire
ils ont droit dès qu'ils sont dans
studio être maquillés il de vannes où
malgré la fatigue de la campagne
électorale avoir une assez bonne mine et
le teint frais droits techniquement à ce
que le réalisateur utilise trois caméras
dites de plateau les caméras de direct
semblable à celle qui vous permettent de
suivre le journal d'antenne de droit un
chronomètre bien visible il a la taille
d'une horloge c'est de la régie le
tableau de commande du studio qu'il est
déclenché des chlorates heures commence
à parler droit enfin des invités tels un
journaliste qui n'est pas nécessairement
un complice et qu'il interroge ce qui
est interdit mais pas question d'avoir
plus de cinq invités pas question
d'utiliser des films même pour évoquer
sa petite enfance ou encore sa carrière
politique
pas question encore de recommencer
l'enregistrement de sa séquence 45 fois
les orateurs ont droit à trois essais
ou encore ils ont le droit de parler en
ré direct à l'heure à laquelle vous
écoutez pas question enfin et surtout de
profiter de leur temps de parole pour
injurier calomnier ou diffamé
recommandations presqu'île utile le
monde politique ne nous at il pas
habitués à une distinction une politesse
et un maintien sans égal en fait cette
campagne c'est une épreuve vérité la
réalisation est dépouillé seul compte un
homme et les idées qu'il porte la
conviction forte arguments doivent
remplacer les prouesses techniques
début donc de cette campagne à la radio
et la télévision dans quelques minutes à
20h35 à 13 jours de ce premier tour de
scrutin et alors que les principaux
leaders politiques vont chaque soir
expliquer leur politique et tenter de
vous convaincre le chef de l'état qui
passe quelques jours de vacances dans le
midi au fort de brégançon le chef de
l'état donc a appelé ce matin les
français à la réflexion monsieur valéry
giscard d'estaing
dans une interview accordée à nos
confrères de tf1 a lancé un nouvel appel
aux français
il est revenu sur ce que devrait être à
ses yeux le bon choix pour la france et
il a fait appel à l'intelligence des
français je sais que les français
réfléchissent je les y invitait la
réflexion à verdun sur le doubs en leur
exposant les données du bon choix pour
la france et depuis ils y réfléchissent
je voudrais faire appel à leur
intelligence l'intelligence des
françaises et des français de toutes
conditions pour un pays comme le dot qui
n'a pas beaucoup de ressources
naturelles son avenir sera déterminé par
sa capacité d'intelligence je souhaite
que le tumulte électorale ne détourne
pas les françaises et les français de
l'essentiel est qu'ils trouvent en eux
mêmes dans leur réflexion et dans leur
intelligence
la réponse à la question grave que leur
pose la france et puis dans cette
campagne électorale les réactions de
l'étranger prennent de plus en plus
d'importance et ainsi qu'entre paris et
copenhague
la brouille s'est installé depuis
quelques jours de couy très exactement
une conférence de presse tenue aux états
unis par le premier ministre danois
monsieur joergensen qui avait estimé
jeudi à washington qu'il n'y aurait pas
de changements importants en france si
la gauche l'emporté qu'à son avis
monsieur françois mitterrand serait sans
doute un bon partenaire au sein du
marché comme une déclaration qui a
suscité l'irritation des autorités
françaises et l'étonnement de monsieur
joergensen devant cette irritation
ce dernier est membre de
l'internationale socialiste il a déclaré
ce matin qu'il ne lui paraissait pas
interdit d'exprimer sa sympathie à un
autre membre de l'internationale
socialiste une réaction qui n'a pas
beaucoup plu au parti libéral danois qui
de son côté a demandé à monsieur
joergensen de présenter ses excuses au
gouvernement france au-delà de cette
mini crise politique elle ne durera
probablement que le temps d'une élection
l'étranger regarde tout de même de très
près ce qui se passe en france hier nous
avons vu comment les italiens réagissait
au scrutin des 12 et 19 mars ce soir
avec l'eau de gagnières je vous propose
de passer la manche et d'aller voir
comment les anglais voient ces élections
avec humour
ces coupes de champagne ces petits fours
ses froufrous et c'est poitrine
charmante tout ça pour l'inauguration
d'une officine de paris une officine
plutôt bien situer puisque en plein
coeur de la cité là où tous les jours on
met en jeu sa fortune en tout cas en
partie sur les cours de la bourse les
actions la monnaie et le taux de change
dans cette officine les mêmes vont
parier sur les chevaux le vainqueur de
la coupe du monde de football et les
élections françaises selon précisément
on inaugure et jamais jusqu'à présent
personne n'a pas rien et pour les
élections françaises
le directeur a dû fixer lui-même la côte
et il a donné la droite légèrement d'une
courte tête
vainqueurs seulement ça a été un vrai
casse tête chinois le programme commun
l'union de la gauche l'accord deuxième
tour
les gaullistes pour un anglais c'est pas
facile bref comment directeur at il dû
fixer la côte du manège to fix
cela a été très difficile je me suis
longtemps demandé si la gauche en france
allait réussir à s'unir
auquel cas je leur ai donné gagnant mais
le week-end dernier je me suis dit qu'il
était trop tard pour cette union et nous
avons parié dès lors sur la victoire de
la majorité actuelle
c'est en contradiction avec les sondages
mais nous avons notre propre
appréciation
et puis les français n'aiment pas trop
le changement il y avait une dizaine de
députés ce jour d'inauguration et nous
leur avons demandé leur opinion
les travaillistes souhaitent une
victoire de la gauche avec un parti
socialiste aussi fort que possible pour
limiter l'influencé communiste quand on
s'interroge sur le rôle qu'ils pourront
jouer on fait remarquer qu'il n'y a
pratiquement pas de pc en grande
bretagne ce qui m'étonne moi
personnellement ce sont ces luttes
public ces insultes que con qu'on
s'échange entre de ses deux partenaires
dans une alliance prospectif de la
gauche
sa démarche est qui insulte non
seulement giscard d'estaing ça on
accepterait mes insultes aussi son
partenaire est selon les sondages qu'on
lit dans la presse chez nous et la
gauche retient toujours ce à la majorité
selon les sondages chez nous les
sondages aurait donné une influence
aurait réfléter l'influencent très
négatif des mythes public les
conservateurs souhaitent la victoire de
la majorité actuelle et eux aussi sont
étonnés par les sondages qui donnent
aujourd'hui avantage à la gauche
oui ça m'étonne un peu quoique je dois
avouer que bien sûr après vingt ans de
5eme république il ya des gens qui dit
irait peut-être un peu raisonnable non
s'il voulait il faut avoir un changement
mais il ya une différence énorme entre
un changement rationnelle et peut-être
un peu gradualiste et un changement
violent c'est ça qui également nous
tracasse ici qu'est ce qu'il pourrait
faire ensemble les socialistes et les
communistes il faut rappeler toujours
n'est ce pas que les socialistes
français le parti socialiste c'est
beaucoup plus gauchiste que les autres
partis socialistes des pays européens y
compris l'angleterre même jamais une
élection française n'aura été autant
suivi en grande-bretagne thème général
des articles la certitude d'un résultat
qui pourrait changer le visage de la
france est l'interrogation que constitue
l'accès éventuel au pouvoir des
communistes
vous l'avez constaté les anglais ont
bien sûr une manière tout à fait
particulière à la race anglaise pour
parler des élections législatives
françaises et pour parler en général de
la politique
le chef de l'état comme il l'avait fait
à l'égard de la marine nationale en
visitant l'école navale
il ya quelques semaines se rend demain à
salon de provence pour y rencontrer les
poussins et tous ceux qui feront bientôt
partie du personnel navigant personnel
officier navigants ou non navigant de
l'armée de l'air les poussent à ce sont
les élèves de l'école de l'air des
jeunes gens qui seront dans quelques
mois les pilotes de notre armée le chef
de l'état ne passera que quelques heures
dans cette école de salon le temps tout
de même de faire connaissance avec le
personnel de l'armée de l'air et aussi
avec les appareils qui la composent des
mirage iii le mirage iv les mirage f1
etc etc
ces sommes sont élèves pilotes à
salon-de-provence ils sont âgés pour la
plupart d'une vingtaine d'années et
porte le grade de sous lieutenant
officiel est des ingénieurs ce sont des
scientifiques avec le goût de l'aventuré
je pense que la motivation essentielle
la première est l' envie de voler un
goût profond pour l'aviation et
j'imagine que l'individu qui s'engagent
par exemple dans l'armée de l'air
découvre au bout de quelque temps qu'il
ya la possibilité de prendre des
responsabilités qui sont très
intéressantes
d'une part en pilotant un avion qui ma
foi représente quelque chose de bien
précis
et puis ensuite en étant amenés à
conduire des hommes
pilote mécanicien ou officiers chargés
du service au sol reçoivent tous la même
formation de base à salon-de-provence
celle de l'officier puis de l'ingénieur
au bout de deux années
chacun poursuit sa formation dans sa
spécialité la durée des études à l'école
de l'air et de trois ans la
spécialisation d'un an ou plus que ce
soit pour la dissuasion ou pour
l'intervention l'extérieur et face à une
stratégie clé face à une tactique la
défense aérienne le transport aérien
militaire tous ses moyens cern
aujourd'hui comme hier la défense du
pays et pour mettre en oeuvre ces moyens
là il faut des jeunes capables d'exercer
pleinement des responsabilités souvent
très importante qui leur sont données et
l début de leur carrière
il faut que ces jeunes qu'ils soient
pilotes de combats qu'ils soient
contrôleurs qu'ils soient mécanicien
soir on pige au domaine technique dans
lequel ils vont vivre le sport à salon
de provence fait aussi partie de la
formation des officiers
il représente près de 40% des activités
pour être un bon technicien un bon
pilote
selon l'encadrement il faut être en
parfaite condition physique
les femmes sont admises depuis 1976 à
cette école de l'air comme les hommes
elles recherchent elle aussi les
responsabilités entre officiers j'aurai
des responsabilités beaucoup plus tôt
que d'hommes civile c'est à dire que
j'aurais à peu près sous mes ordres 80
personnes et j'aurai la responsabilité
non seulement de ce personnel mais aussi
d'un matériel
trop technicité ses responsabilités à 23
ans les a pas d'un civil et c'est ça qui
m'a attiré dans cette carrière militaire
les places sont limitées pour les femmes
à salon-de-provence 3 pour 74 hommes
recrutés cette année ils sont exclus du
métier de pilote et occuperont après
leur formation des postes de mécanicien
contrôleur aérien ou officiers des bases
l'armée de l'air recrute chaque année
moins d'une centaine d'étudiants sur
près d'un millier de candidats on trouve
un salon 25% de fils des militaires 30%
de fils de cadres et 45% de fils de
fonctionnaires d'employer le commerçant
ou d'agriculteurs
la plupart d'entre eux s'engagent avant
tout pour piloter un avion
les meilleurs décolleront peut-être un
jour aux commandes de ces mêmes
appareils d fouga magister pour évoluer
avec cette patrouille de france
également basée à salon de provence dans
le domaine économique le dollar et
depuis ce matin à la hausse le franc
suisse à la baisse tandis que le mark
allemand et la livre sterling continuent
leur lente mais régulière progression
la baisse du franc suisse explique du
côté de genève de berne vient de zurich
les autorités helvétiques ont décidé de
stopper l'ascension de la manne issue
c'est ainsi que les étrangers ne peuvent
plus acquérir de valeurs suisses et que
les billets de banque étrangers ne sont
plus acceptés en suisse qu'à concurrence
de 20 mille francs par trimestre et par
personne la querelle entre les petites
et les moyennes entreprises et l'edf et
bien cette querelle s'est retrouvé
aujourd'hui devant le tribunal un
tribunal qui a débouté aujourd'hui le
syndicat national des pmi qui demandait
la bagatelle de 75 millions de francs à
la suite des grèves de l'edf de décembre
dernier les pmi les petites et moyennes
industries estimé avoir subi un
préjudice elle demandé la nomination
d'un expert le tribunal des référés en a
jugé autrement
les pmi ont cependant décidé de
poursuivre leur action en justice aux
philippines monsieur pierre huguet ce
directeur du ministère des finances
français est toujours porté disparu ce
haut fonctionnaire a été enlevé vendredi
par des rebelles musulmans alors qu'il
participait avec son épouse un voyage
organisé il était en vacances
actuellement les autorités des
philippines conserve un espoir d'établir
un contact avec les ravisseurs
d'obtenir la libération de notre
compatriote c'est une tâche qui sera
toutefois difficile plusieurs
enlèvements ont eu lieu en 1976 dans
cette même région où la sécurité il faut
le dire est permanente et la surrection
aussi
basile and une île du sud des
philippines à quelque 900 km de manille
la capitale
c'est là que serait détenu monsieur
huguet après son enlèvement par les
rebelles musulmans en plein coeur de la
ville de zamboanga où ils faisaient du
tourisme
voilà dix ans que les quatre millions de
musulmans du sud des philippines se bat
contre le pouvoir du président marcos
pour obtenir l'autonomie d'une dizaine
de provinces
le front de libération moro qui regroupe
plus de 30 mille combattants musulmans
tient tête à une armée bien équipée
mais incapables de contrôler cette
jungle les combats ont déjà fait dix
mille morts et près de cent mille
réfugiés
bien que certains chefs de la rébellion
est signé de leur sang un traité de paix
avec le gouvernement et même rendu
symboliquement des armes les cessez le
feu ont toujours été rompu et les
enlèvements ont repris monsieur guay est
ainsi le 40e touristes étrangers qui
tombent dans le piège des rebelles qui
avaient lu un livre que j'avais écrit
sur les philippines est venu me dire bon
les zoulous ça m'intéresse de les voir
je voudrais aller voir surtout l'île de
basilan qui se trouve à une heure d'une
ou deux heures de bateau de zamboanga
alors yeux on l'a mis en garde cette
situation assez explosif qu'il existe là
bas lui disant dans le sud des
philippines si le nord est aucun
problème de sécurité dans le sud à
mindanao il ya deux zones à peu près
sûrs qu'ils sont la région de davao et
zamboanga même mais dès que vous sortez
de la ville il vous devez demander d'une
part les autorisations et d'une part
vous renseigner si ça peut être fait
sans risque car il y a comme un héros là
les bases ilan je lui ai expliqué que le
nom de mon dernier voyage aux
philippines je n'avais pu me rendre
parce qu'elle est problèmes de sécurité
il y avait des élections
hier au sénégal des élections
présidentielles des élections
législatives et aussi des élections
communales c'est à dire l'équivalent de
nos élections municipales et pour la
première fois peut-être en afrique
les résultats ne se solde pas par des
99.99 en faveur du parti actuellement au
pouvoir
c'est qu'au sénégal l'opposition hier a
eu droit de cité
et d'après les premiers résultats certes
le président léopold sédar senghor est
assuré de sa réélection son parti le
parti socialiste sénégalais est
également assuré de conserver la
majorité au parlement mais l'opposition
était là
et bien cette opposition le parti
démocratique sénégalais de monsieur wad
obtiendrait le dépouillement n'est pas
encore tout à fait terminée entre 15 et
30% des suffrages exprimés
pendant que des élections démocratiques
se dérouler au sénégal et ce pour la
première fois donc depuis bien longtemps
en afrique de l'autre côté du continent
la guerre se poursuit la corne de
l'afrique tend à devenir la poudrière de
ce continent et par les influences qui
s'y manifeste peut-être la poudrière du
monde une fois plus en effet jean
françois kahn en ethiopie et en somalie
c'est l'affrontement est ouest qui se
produit c'est la guerre par cubain et
qui obtient et ce malien interposés
entre finalement deux conceptions de la
politique en afrique ce qui se passe sur
tout et c'est ça qui est assez assez
extraordinaire c'est que pour la
deuxième fois en moins de deux ans les
soviets aux cubains disons pour
simplifier sont en train de remporter un
succès militaire et psychologique tout à
fait considérable
la dernière fois c'était en angola et ce
qui est étonnant c'est que les deux fois
et bien on a vu les soviets aux cubains
prendre complètement à contre-pied les
occidentaux en profitant des mêmes
erreurs que ces occidentaux au commis
rappelez vous ce qui se passait en
angola vous souvenez en angola il y
avait sept heures cette ancienne colonie
portugaise était devenue indépendante et
il y avait des nationalistes
communisants et des anticommunistes qui
se disputaient et les occidentaux ont
fait l'erreur de laisser intervenir les
sud africains pourquoi était ce une
erreur parce qu'à partir du moment où
des sud-africains intervenait et bien ça
pouvait donner le prétexte à n'importe
qui d'autre d'intervenir en disant qu'il
venait au secours de l'autre partie
seulement à ce moment là on n'avait pas
tellement vu l'enjeu parce qu'on se
disait les soviétiques vont pas arriver
on va pouvoir lés soviétiques avec leurs
chars
arrivé comme ça en afrique les
soviétiques sont pas arrivés mais les
cubains sont arrivés et personne n'avait
imaginé ça que des noirs cubain vianne
comme ça en afrique et la thur ne
pouvait rien faire parce qu'il venait au
secours d'un pays agressés par les
sud-africains et bien la même erreur a
été commise en ethiopie et en somalie
les occidentaux ont laissé la somalie
intervenir en ethiopie agressé d'une
certaine manière les topics car on peut
penser ce qu'on veut de l'ethiopie qui
est un régime sanguinaire et par
certaines une certaine façon affreux
mais c'est un fait que les troupes
somaliennes sont intervenus en ethiopie
et du même coup cela a permis aux
soviétiques et aux cubains d'intervenir
en se présentant comme des défenseurs
contre une agression extérieure et
pourquoi ton commis une nouvelle fois
cette erreur parce que là on s'était dit
les soviétiques sont installés aussi
bien en somalie en ethiopie ce sont deux
pays qui se réclame du socialisme
marxiste léniniste
alors ils vont pas quand même soutenir
un pays contraint nos seulement en fait
et soviétiques ont choisi pour des
raisons bien simple que j'aimerais c'est
que la somalie est un pays où vous avez
trois millions d'habitants et l'ethiopie
à pia 28 millions d'habitants neuf fois
plus et le revenu national 1 million 300
millions et un milliard de francs
environ en somalie 12 milliards en
ethiopie deux fois plus ou alors mis au
point de vue économique rire la richesse
de ces pays et bien l'union soviétique
n'a pas hésité elle a choisi celui qui
était le plus fort et le plus riche et
donc elle intervient et l'est de
l'ethiopie a remporté finalement une
victoire ce qui fait qu'en afrique
beaucoup de gens se disent qu'il est
beaucoup plus rentable d'être alliés aux
soviets aux cubains que occidentaux
enfin sur le caniveau rester avec moi
car il se passe aussi dans un pays que
vous connaissez bien d une insurrection
à ce moment c'est au nicaragua où nous
venons de l'apprendre des civils ont été
tués aujourd'hui à un mouvement
d'insurrection généralisée c'est
semble-t-il le déclarer contre le
président somoza le président qui le
peut être le plus vieux dictateur enfin
sa famille la plus vieille dictature du
monde ça vienne nous arriver dans la
chanson viens d'apprendre
je crois que c'est très émouvant ce qui
se passe simplement rapidement c'est
très émouvant ce qui se passe au
nicaragua parce que ça fait 40 ans que
la même famille des samovars gouverne le
pays mais d'une façon incroyablement
dictatorial est une vraie caricature de
dictature et cette famille de dictateurs
possède jeudi à possède 30% du pays elle
a acheté
n'est ce pas 30% du pays c'est à m et
depuis trois semaines on assiste à une
véritable insurrection populaire comme
on en voit peu aujourd'hui vraiment
femmes enfants sont en train de
participer à la révolte contre cette
dictature d'une information
nous suivrons et nous aurons
rassemblement vers 23h d'autres
renseignements gérard holtz où les
donnera ce moment en inde au vote est
également fière une surprise le parti
dirigé par madame indira gandhi qui
entre parenthèses a été mise en liberté
sous caution le parti donc dirigé par
amine dia gandhi l'a emporté très
nettement dans l'état du karnataka sur
les 224 sièges à pourvoir
125 ont d'ores et déjà été attribués aux
partisans de madame gande là aussi le
dépouillement n'est pas terminée demain
nous aurons les résultats de cinq autres
états de l'union indienne cinq états qui
représentent à eux seuls 60 millions
d'électeurs et puis si je continue mon
tour du monde j'arrive tout
naturellement aux états unis là bas pas
question d'électricité d'élections
pardon mais d'une grève d'une grève si
l'on qu'elle met en péril une bonne
partie de l'économie des états unis
les mineurs de charbon ont cessé le
travail depuis près de trois mois
résultat l'électricité est rationnée
dans certains états et les centaines de
milliers de travailleurs risquent de se
retrouver assez rapidement au chômage
sans électricité comment faire tourner
les usines et sans charbon
comment faire de l'électricité et le
pire pour l'administration américaine
c'est que cette grève est bien elle
pourrait durer encore longtemps dans
cette vallée longue de 20 kilomètres
on extrait le charbon dans la montagne
des mines à ciel ouvert
ici c'est le district 17 à 500 km
environ de washington et c'est ici que
les mineurs ont mené la grève la plus
dure la plus longue de toute l'histoire
des états unis
le piquet de grève ici n'existe pas pour
la simple raison que toute la vallée a
cessé le travail depuis le 6 décembre et
le contremaître de cette mine à ciel
ouvert ont fait des trous dans la
montagne pourront puiser le charbon le
contremaître rappelle que cabine quick
et le district 17 ont une longue
tradition de m il a su par les gens
disent que l'an dernier il y a eu aussi
une grève de dix semaines
cette année les mineurs du distributeur
réclamait le droit de déclencher des
grèves locales sans être menacé de
renvoi et le remboursement total de
leurs frais médicaux pratique tout à
fait inhabituelle aux états unis au
total ce sont 170 mille mineurs qui dans
les six états américains
charbonnier sont arrivés à entraver très
sérieusement l'économie américaine
et c'est pourquoi carter vient d'obliger
patron est mineur à se mettre d'accord
mais rien n'est vraiment réglé à
charlton la capitale de la virginie
occidentale
les responsables de l'union des mineurs
sont réservées ne pense pas que les
mineurs abandonneront leur avantage
après une lutte de plus de 80 jours 17
heures et président du district après
l'accord passé ce week-end les mineurs
ont dix jours pour se prononcer ils
n'ont pas obtenu gain de cause sur le
droit de grève
il n'aurait donc rejeté l'accord conclu
à washington et faillit poursuivre la
grève c'est dans ce cadre carter ferait
appel à l'armée pour obliger les mineurs
à reprendre le travail
pour l'heure les américains s'inquiètent
les réserves de charbon s'épuise et
l'hiver n'a jamais été aussi long et
froid certains états ont rationner
l'électricité et certaines usines
licencient leurs impayés mais dans la
vallée de cabine quick on répète
inlassablement pas de contrat pas de
travail
cela fait trois ans nous préparions à
cette grève où ces jeunes mineurs
nous avons fait des économies nous
pourrons tenir
on saura dans une dizaine de jours
seulement si carter a pu surmonter cette
crise la plus longue grève des mineurs
aux états unis dans le cas contraire la
situation économique serait alarmante
aussi millions de chômeurs actuels
viendrait s'ajouter ceux engendrés par
le conflit du charbon
c'est une mésaventure curieuse qui est
arrivé un cafetier de la région de
charleroi en belgique cet homme aime
bien les animaux
il en avait et toute une collection chez
lui sa fierté s'appelait zoé isolé c'est
un superbe cobra royal hier soir on ne
sait pas très bien ce qui s'est passé ce
cafetier belge at-il marché sur
l'accueil ou bien le cobra et il
mécontent de l'ordinaire nul ne le sait
ce qui est certain c'est que le cobra a
mordu le caf t-il que pour soigner le
cafetier les médecins belges ont fait
appel à l'hôpital pasteur à paris que
pour transporter le sérum indispensable
indispensable pardon l'hôpital pasteur a
fait appel à l'armée de l'air et pour
que la viande l'armée de l'air puis se
poser non loin de charleroi il a fallu
réveiller le personnel de l'aéroport et
éclairer les pistes le sérum a tout de
même été administré à temps aux malades
celui ci va mieux le cobra paraît-il est
en pleine santé puisque je suis dans les
histoires d'animaux je vous propose d'y
rester encore une toute petite minute
pour la première fois des français ont
pu assister hier à une course de chiens
de traîneaux cela se passait sur les
pentes du col de la schlucht en alsace y
avait beaucoup de spectateurs pas mal
d'équipage aussi une odyssée digne de
jack london
en quelque sorte
ces chiens de traîneaux sont pour la
plupart de race sibérienne ou bien
groenlandaise ils ont du sens de loups
dans les veines ce qui ne les empêche
pas paraît-il d'être très affectueux les
17 participants à la course ont suivi un
rude entraînement deux heures par jour
et un régime de champion viande crue et
poissons séchés
ensuite il a fallu habitués les bêtes à
courir ensemble et surtout les former un
travail d'équipé avec l'homme c'est un
attelage allemand entraîné en sibérie
qui a remporté l'épreuve
il a mis 16 minutes pour parcourir les 8
km du circuit
mais peu importe la performance ce qui
compte n'est ce pas avant tout livré ce
ressenti au milieu des champs de neige
du moins par l'homme voilà transports
nous connaissons maintenant je ne
trouvais pas la caméra c'était la 3
merci en sports nous connaissons
maintenant la liste des joueurs qui sont
présélectionnés pour jouer contre le
portugal le 8 mars prochain au parc des
princes il s'agit bien sûr de football
et d'un match amical de préparation à la
prochaine coupe du monde qui se jouera
vous le savez bien sûr en argentine
seize joueurs ont été retenus par michel
hidalgo
alors je vous les laisse se découvrir la
lecture de ce petit panneau voilà quant
à jean-baptiste pied vaches là il
s'apprête il s'agit de boxe jean
baptiste pied vaches s'apprête à
rencontrer ce soir au palais des sports
à paris l'américain raul balbi qu'il
s'agit d'une demi finale pour un titre
mondial 6 pieds vachement portes ce soir
il rencontrera titre des super légers en
jeu le 8 juillet prochain
le thaïlandais wang serine j'espère que
je n'accroche pas trop sont dans notre
dernière édition aux alentours de 22h
23h35 pardon gérard holtz vous donnera
le résultat de ce match et puis toujours
en sport je voudrais vous présenter ce
soir deux engins de moto tout à fait
révolutionnaire
la première a été conçu par eric
offenstadt c'est une 5 centimètres cubes
et la seconde qui s'appelle moto fx est
né du cerveau d'andré de corps temps ce
qui est avec nous comme eric offenstadt
ce soit et là c'est une moto vous le
constatez tout à fait révolutionnaire on
parlera de la révolution après tout
c'est eric offenstadt cette moto est
tout de même un peu spectaculaire aussi
un peu surprenante
c'est la première fois qu'on la voit je
crois sur un studio télévisée
on l'a déjà vu en piste quand même tout
au moins sur des pistes d'essai non
celle ci n'a pas tourné mais en fait
c'est un seller le la division c'est
l'addition de toutes les expériences que
j'ai pu faire depuis trois ou quatre ans
et des meilleurs procédés qui sont pour
la première fois réunis pour ce nouveau
tour 100% française
oui le moteur est français la partie
cycle et française également pour ses
motos de course là on le voit tout de
suite c'est pas une moto à mettre entre
toutes les mains vraisemblablement
s'allume alors quel est son aspect le
plus révolutionnaire disons elle a deux
aspects principaux c'est la suspension
avant qui n'est pas du tout une fois je
télescoper comme sur les autres machines
et d'autre part le moteur qui est un
moteur à deux carburateurs par cylindre
ce qui n'existe pas à l'heure actuelle
en compétition c'est une moto de
compétition vous pensez courir avec
prochainement
nous devons débuter au grand prix
d'espagne dans un mois et demi le 16
avril merci eric voilà la moto
révolutionnaire il nous reste alors je
vous le dis tout de suite 45 secondes
pour en parler et encore plus
révolutionnaire que celle d'eric d'abord
parce que elles ne ressentent pas une
moto oui pour moi le problème n'est pas
tout à fait le même que celui d'eric
pour moi c'est une moto de recherche
donc je n'ai pas besoin d'être
opérationnel tout de suite c'est
vraiment une moto expérimental qu'on a
construite dans un but de recherche
dynamique sur la moto pour apporter
quelque chose qu'on ne verra pas sur les
circuits bientôt pas dans l'immédiat
tout au moins bien écouté il est 20h30
je ne voudrais pas mettre en retard les
hommes politiques qui vont parler
bientôt mais as-tu bientôt aux français
alors tout de suite je préfère vous dire
qu'on parlera de la météo dans dans le
dernier journal la météo qui ne sera pas
très bonnes d'ailleurs pour demain je
vous souhaite de passer une très bonne
soirée dans lé journal 23h35 avec gérard
holtz bonsoir